[Music]
many people can only make ends meet in
the cover pandemic by somehow supporting
themselves
people on low incomes often fall through
the cracks of politics and the
authorities this week we'll be showing
you some successful social projects in
argentina and colombia and we'll be
asking how to get the balance right
between cautiousness and the longing for
a halfway normal life in the face of
continuing high infection rates
like in france where almost all kovid
restrictions have been lifted despite
the summer wave of infections that has
just swept across europe
the government's reasoning 80 percent of
the population is fully vaccinated
and infection rates are largely stable
we asked around in the capital paris
what do people think of the end of covid
[Music]
restrictions damia marta is a taxi
driver in paris
and someone who still takes the covet 19
virus very seriously
tamiya keeps masks and hand sanitizers
ready for his passengers
the cab driver nearly lost his father to
the coronavirus during the first wave
two years ago an experience that has
made him extra careful
he says people should not lower their
guard either
my father was in a coma for 10 weeks
when he got covered
he was in a desperate and really
catastrophic state
luckily he came out of it
so i prefer not to take any risks after
everything we've lived through i'm
surprised that people don't take any
precautions anymore it's still dangerous
all these people i see not wearing masks
are actually gambling with their lives
but damier is something of an exception
in paris
on the metro there are few signs of
passengers taking precautionary measures
in may the government said people were
no longer required to wear masks on
public transportation
now the authorities have gone further
the french parliament recently adopted a
bill lifting a state of health emergency
imposed at the beginning of the pandemic
starting august 1st all measures put in
place to fight covet in france have
ended that includes everything from
curfews emergency lockdowns remote
working the wearing of face masks and
holding a health pass to access museums
or restaurants
the lifting of covet restrictions has
been welcomed by many
especially at paris's tourist hot spots
after a two-year break visitors are once
again flocking to the french capital
i don't think imposing restrictions on
people is a good thing we're all human
and we're all free it goes against
personal liberty
on the streets it's so much nicer now to
see people's faces to see them smiling
is so much more livable but others
remain wary
we're still afraid of the new variant of
the coronovirus
a few days ago we've been to disneyland
which is so crowded and nobody
was worried nobody was wearing a mask
health authorities are still monitoring
new infections and the end of the state
of health emergency has not changed
france's policy on testing
this pharmacy says the number of people
coming in for covet tests has dropped
drastically
but that could change once parisians
return from the summer holidays
the restrictions should be lifted
progressively step by step and not end
it overnight there are places like
public transportation or pharmacies
where the mask is recommended but not
mandatory but it should be we have to
take care of people who are vulnerable
and at times seriously sick i strongly
expect a rise in positive covet cases
for his part isn't taking any chances he
preps his taxi carefully before taking
on his next passenger damia has not
contracted kovitz so far
and he intends to keep it that way
finally freedom serenity hope for a
return to normal life or should we
remain cautious about the risk of
infection dw reporter stephanie torbel
talked to epidemiologist ralph ranches
from the university of applied sciences
in hamburg he's part of a european task
force that monitors pandemics
[Music]
in france many of the current
coronavirus restrictions were lifted on
august 1st what do you think of that
that was a political decision
on the one hand one can really
understand the people who are sick and
tired of the pandemic
but of course at the end of the summer
wave it will make it easier for the
virus to spread in france
with all the restrictions lifted how can
people be persuaded to wear masks again
in the fall if infection numbers rise
what's really really important is a
clear risk communication strategy
so that in the fall it's made absolutely
clear how high the risk of reinfection
is in order to motivate people to
protect themselves properly
what would a risk communication strategy
look like
and clearly showing how the virus is
spread
and by urging the need for cooperation
collaboration from all parties to
control its spread
meaning that we're in the same boat and
that we want to move forward and not
experience another extremely big wave in
the fall and winter
in germany ministers have proposed a
road map for the fall from october 1st
it will be mandatory to wear an ffp2
mask for long distance travel and on
airplanes in germany as well as a mask
and test mandate in hospitals and care
facilities do you think that makes sense
it certainly makes a lot of sense right
now a lot of people are coming close to
one another on public transport on a
regular basis often over extended
periods of time
now on trains and airplanes people sit
next to each other for long periods of
time and that's where a mask mandate is
extremely helpful
it would be great if there would be a
nationwide mask mandate on local public
transport too and in places where
vulnerable people live naturally it
makes sense not to introduce viruses
there
does it make sense that politicians have
already ruled out further closures and
lockdowns
that's a very very good question we're
all hoping that these measures won't
become necessary again
but we can't be 100 sure how the
situation will look in fall and winter
and then of course from an
epidemiological perspective we can't
rule out any measures at the moment
rather try to do everything possible to
avoid it
what would you do differently if you
were making the decisions i've been
well i'm a scientist and i'm trying to
make sense of the pandemic and proceed
accordingly
i would very much like to try that with
a different risk communication strategy
to further increase trust
so that we can all enjoy our freedom
with the right awareness and the
knowledge and also know where our limits
are where the dangers lie
and i think mask mandates indoors for
example in all public buildings in the
fall and winter would certainly make a
lot of sense
sciences in hamburg
you're welcome
paraguay became a target destination for
german vaccination opponents during the
pandemic
some even moved there to avoid getting
vaccinated
in their supposed paradise however these
germans are not particularly welcome
[Music]
paraguay's relaxed coveted rules have
seen german anti-vaxxers flock to the
country
there have even been cases where a
parent has taken their child to paraguay
without the other parent knowing all to
escape the vaccine
overall several thousand germans have
arrived in the south american country
which has one of the world's worst
health systems
stefan schweiz is a german paraguayan
lawyer he helped one mother who spent
six months looking for her daughter
after she was abducted by her father
this is no isolated case it was a
particularly sensitive one but we have
several in paraguay
he says many come without knowing
anything about paraguay and then
struggle
there are plenty of quite extreme cases
where people arrive in paraguay without
knowing anything of the language or the
conditions here
in my opinion it's just crazy
they leave everything of their old life
behind
they sell their houses
load up a container and just turn up
here
and many of them come with children too
and in paraguay it's not that easy to
find a job for example even if you do
speak the language
well over 1600 new arrivals from germany
were processed by paraguay's immigration
authorities in 2021 that's nearly three
times as many as the year before
the numbers have shot up over the last
two years because of the coronavirus
but political events have also played a
role
like the war in ukraine
which many of these people are worried
and yet about
is not safer than germany we spoke to
guillermo zakira an epidemiologist in
charge of monitoring national health
if they're hoping for good health care
and a well-functioning
our health system is one of the most
precarious in the americas
i can see that people coming from
countries like germany and austria are
going to suffer here
paraguay is experiencing a fourth wave
of covet 19 but with death rates lower
than in previous waves saket is
concerned about the german influx for
another reason
epidemics that have not existed in
paraguay for more than 20 years could be
reintroduced
things like measles for example
or polio which we haven't had for more
than 30 years
these are diseases that people who are
not vaccinated can reintroduce when you
don't have a good health system
we've come to the german paraguayan
cultural institute its director zimona
hendrich moved here from germany 22
years ago she too is concerned about the
current trend
i follow some channels on telegram
i find some of the things posted by the
germans who come here quite scary
she's vaccinated against covert 19 to
protect herself and others she says many
people arriving from germany come to her
asking for a job but they don't want to
get vaccinated
it's a very diverse group too very large
with different religions different
opinions
but it has a dark side to it too
the new arrivals mean the german
community here is much more diverse lars
classen grew up here he's a computer
programmer of german mennonite origin
i know people here in paraguay who
oppose the vaccine
and they have their reasons
but they're in the minority
most of my friends are in favor of the
vaccine
he himself has three coveted vaccine
shots just like his wife and children
i wouldn't describe paraguay as any kind
of paradise for germans who oppose
science
and of course not all germans coming to
paraguay do
the contact restrictions during the
covert pandemic had massive social
consequences for many people
in poorer neighborhoods of the
argentinian capital buenos aires
neighbours set up community support
groups and the idea became a huge
success both in the fight against kovid
and for social cohesion
in 2020 in the midst of the coronavirus
pandemic residents and experts created a
crisis committee in the mujica villa 31
suburb of buenos aires it was set up to
address the needs of the locals the
committee was even recognised by the
government
founding member silvana oliveira tells
us about some of the group's biggest
successes including el tetectar
el detector was the name of a coveted
testing truck that the government sent
around the various neighborhoods
he could walk up get swapped and you'd
have your result within 24 hours
if it was positive you'd be taken to a
coveted hotel to isolate
and we had free
canteens those are one of the group's
biggest achievements
thanks to the committee these free
neighborhood canteens multiplied and
strengthened during the pandemic
they were funded by government subsidies
and donations from private institutions
we weren't given much food
only enough for 57 portions
but we always made more than 57 portions
because so many people had lost their
jobs during the pandemic
we had hundreds of people looking for
food
for decades the city government has been
trying to strategically expel people
from the mohica neighborhood
it's located very close to the financial
district and the port the most lucrative
areas of buenos aires which makes it all
the more important for people here to
unite and mobilize
if there's one thing that people in poor
neighborhoods of argentina are known for
or in any vulnerable community in the
world in fact it's self-organization
the committee couldn't meet during the
first wave of covert due to the
restrictions imposed by the argentinian
government
but the cristo obrero church then
offered its facilities to the group to
meet under strict covert requirements
it was here that most of the suggestions
put forward by the committee were set in
motion
priest guillermo torres was in charge at
the time
it was like a network we had shelters
some people cooked some gave health
advice others looked after the elderly
at home the committee also brought a lot
of issues to light that people didn't
know about only the residents know the
true reality
the muhika via 31 neighborhood is home
to most of the capital's manual workers
and day labourers
forming organised groups is especially
important in these impoverished areas of
the country because they make the
problems that burden them more visible
today our committee is strong
we clearly set an example of how to
fight for your neighborhood
because other crisis committees were
later set up elsewhere
this was the start of the fight for
health rights in poor neighborhoods
during the pandemic
the neighborhood is currently undergoing
a redevelopment project which is
followed and monitored by the committee
the group hopes to continue their work
after the pandemic
what would you like to know about kovid
our science editor derek williams has
the lowdown on the latest research and
analysis
just write to covertproducer dw.com
[Music]
this week he answers the question
do some people have genes that give them
advantages against covid19
this is a super interesting question and
and one where lots of research is going
on in a lot of different areas um let's
look at a few of them starting with
blood types which of course are
genetically determined
since the early days of the pandemic
there have been
many many studies on whether your blood
group could play a role in covid
severity
or mortality like this fairly recent one
from researchers at king's college in
the uk
which looked at three thousand different
proteins found in blood now it found
that six variants seem to make the
disease worse if you have them while
eight variants
seem to make it better but there's of
course no smoking gun that says one
blood type
saves or condemns you people of all
blood types can and do get the disease
another area where genes could play a
role is in how they impact on immune
response
a recent study by german researchers
that looked at that question
found that a particular variant of a
gene called
gnb3 that it seems to be linked to lower
mortality now gnb3
plays a role in activating immune cells
so it would kind of make sense if a
highly effective variant of it provided
some clear protective benefits um other
genes linked to the immune system also
almost
certainly feed into risk for example
those that make some people more likely
to develop diabetes or those that make
people more likely to experience a
life-threatening cytokine storm if they
catch the disease
finally there's the idea that some
people might actually be genetically
immune to covet 19.
hypothetical territory we know for
example that having highly specific
variants of a particular gene that that
makes a small group of people basically
immune
to hiv
they simply don't catch it
might there be
similar genetic variants that could
somehow prevent someone from
catching covid
maybe
one area that's being looked at closely
is what's called the ace2 receptor
that's a protein
on a cell's surface
that the virus subverts to break in now
if someone's genes cause them to produce
an altered version of ace2 it could at
least in theory
prevent the virus from latching on
making that person effectively immune
now if that kind of genetic variant
exists a big if
then the group of people who have it is
likely very small but it would be great
to discover something like that because
it would give researchers designing
medications against the disease a really
massive
foot forward just as it did with
designing medications
for treating hiv
[Music]
when colombia's capital bogota was in
lockdown venezuelan migrants in
particular had little chance of finding
a job
workshops run by a local charity aimed
to solve that
in a sewing workshop some very special
clothes were created with each garment
also representing a chance for a better
life
[Music]
one of the most dangerous neighborhoods
in bogota whimsical dresses are on
display
they were made during the pandemic and
tell of the dreams of venezuelan migrant
women
one in particular stands out in the
colors of the flags of colombia and
venezuela
at the sewing box we made the dress of
dreams it includes people from venezuela
as well as colombia
nationality doesn't matter
it means that we're all united by the
dress
we asked the women at the sewing box to
write messages that spoke to everyone's
dreams
and then we all started writing down our
dreams and sewing them together
the dress is an example of a sewing box
collaboration created after the lockdown
during the coveted waves the 15 women
who worked on the dress had been badly
affected by the covet restrictions
the sewing box is an initiative of the
procreate foundation
during lockdown many migrant women
experienced violence in their shelters
we were looking for a sanctuary
the sewing box gives women the
opportunity to have a safe place and an
income and to put their sewing ideas
into action such as designing symbolic
dresses
they can start a small business and earn
money for what they do
during lockdown the sewing box was
forced to close
when it reopened the women here set to
work making masks and protective suits
when they told us we could return to the
sewing box i was so happy
i said
let's release the doves
we'll fly again and here we are now
meeting and talking with one another
for many women here the sewing box is a
refuge from the problems in bogota's
neighborhoods
[Music]
the neighborhood here isn't as dear to
me as my original home in venezuela but
the sewing box is when i sew i get
distance from the problems in the area
then it's as if i'm not here as if this
neighborhood didn't exist
[Music]
with the money they earned after the
lockdown the women have begun to realize
their dream to be able to make a living
from sewing and designing clothes
i started to work
i bought a sewing machine with the money
i earned
i call it senor paper
it's paper but it sometimes gets jammed
now the women are sewing uniforms and
applying what they learned during the
pandemic
sandra ulya was their teacher
fashion is always new
it never ends
there are always new materials new
designs
everyone wants something new
that's why it never ends
new ideas for clothes were born in the
pandemics
lots of businesses went bust during the
pandemic but the sewing box made it
through
always keep going for us
the women will continue to meet here at
their refuge it makes them feel like
they're part of something very special
and that's all from this week's covert
19 special thanks for watching and see
you next time
[Music]
you